(whooshing)
- You're giving advice right now,
and like some people on
the other side right now
are gonna do the scary
version of it and be in jail.
(cheering)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
(announcer shouting)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody.
It's Gary Vaynerchuk
New interview session
right now with Josh York.
Let me see this simple.
There's a single, single reason
this episode is happening,
and it's called perseverance.
I am a big fan,
excuse me,
of telling a lot of you
right now to dm a hundred
like every day, all I hear is complaining.
I read it all day.
My life is garbage these days,
all I do is read complaining.
And there's so much solutions
in an internet world
that it just makes me
like, I'm so passionate,
if you're listening right now,
for people to know how in
control you actually are
with the internet
'cause the internet doesn't
know what school you went to,
where you came from, what
your family's last name is.
It's just a platform.
And so when I say my hyperbole of like,
hey, you know like just
DM a hundred people
that you wanna work for,
or like, make like, just
make content for somebody
and show them like,
(Josh York mumbles)
just take it.
Like, I mean it, like 4,000 will say no,
but 4,001 says yes,
and isn't that better than
the shit job you have?
Like, everyone's like,
"I wanna live my dream".
I'm like, if I told you
you would 100% have your dream come true
if you actually dmed on
Instagram 4,001 people,
I would argue almost everybody
would do that logically.
It's just that you don't
believe me when I say it.
And so the reason I really
wanted Josh on the show
is like, he just basically out
willed me to be on the show.
Like, just like, and then
when I sat down with him,
I did some speech in like the upper East
or West side, and then
we had coffee or lunch,
and like, basically that's
all he's ever really done.
And very honestly, like, he's
here for his selfish wants
and needs of exposure, which is right,
all humans are right, in a good way.
I'm here selfishly, because I think
me setting up this podcast
and telling you how we even got on it,
now, what's gonna happen
next is 8,000 of you
are gonna bug the shit out of me,
and I'll tell you right now 7,999 of you
will never be here.
You know, it took, you know,
serendipity moments in time,
and the fact that he's
actually built something,
which is an important part of this story,
but for there to be no confusion,
there's one selfish
reason he's on this show
which is, every one of
you can have the business,
the job, the show you wanna be on,
if you actually understand how to ask,
I do think that there is a
fine line between annoyance,
I mean there's so many people
bugging the living shit
out of me right?
Actively right now, there
are thousands of people
bothering me with the
way they're emailing me.
My favorite is when you
email me 97 times in a row
thinking that's gonna,
what happens is, my admins delete it,
and then the IT department
blocks your email
[Josh] Blocks them, (laughs)
- and anything to associate
with you in perpetuity.
So like, there's a right way to jab.
There's the right way to have,
listen, the perfect balance
of persistence and charm
is very difficult.
It is a natural innate thing,
but here's what I will say.
If you try to figure
out how to bring value to somebody
and you persevere, like,
I really do think there's a play here.
And honestly, to be very frank
I think Josh built a
really meaningful business.
I'm not in a mindset of investing now,
I'd rather buy sports cars
than invest in companies,
but even though it wasn't
like a perfect execution
for me of like, I'm getting this value
then let me have him on the podcast,
it was so important for me to have
actual human manifestation
of the thing that I want
all of you to do out there
which is like, look, if you
wanna be a producer for rap,
like go ask 47,000 times, Metro Boomin,
you know, Sonny digital, like Murder beat,
like just fucking ask,
like, fuck, ask now.
If you know how to ask with grace,
it's gonna work better.
If you know how to reverse
engineer the person
of what they care about at this moment.
Like if somebody has
a new album coming out
and they're your favorite rapper,
Young Nudy has an album out today.
If Nudy is your guy,
like, you could've made
25 pieces of content,
if you're that person and sent a dm to him
to help him post on his social channels,
'cause everybody needs more content,
and then that might've been
the reason you got the job.
So there's a cadence to it.
There's one huge setup,
'cause I'm gonna let Josh talk
most of the rest of the way
of why he's here,
and that's it.
That's fucking it.
What's up bro?
- Not much, listen, first off, I wanna say
is that the value is
definitely coming your way.
- Okay, good.
- And I'm telling you
right now, not to be ballsy
but this is gonna go down
as the greatest podcast
you've ever done.
The content is gonna be pouring
through this microphone.
I'm telling you that right now.
- I believe you
- 'Cause my story is incredible,
I've done it bootstrapped,
as I like to refer
to a shoe dog in it,
I've done it bootstrapped,
today we are the fastest
growing in the fitness space,
We're disrupting the
entire fitness industry
and in 15, 20 years, just like I know
you're gonna own the jets
and I know why you're gonna own it
'cause you already own it in your head.
I'm the same guy as you.
I know exactly how you think.
- So just help everybody who hears that,
why do so many people
have it in their head
and it doesn't happen?
What's the disconnect between having it
in your head, and it actually happening
From your perspective.
- Yeah well, first of all,
everyone wants the gold
but people just say,
"You know what?
"I'll settle for the silver".
People don't actually
cross the finish line.
People,
I just--
- Why?
- Number one
- From your perspective,
one man's point of view.
- [Josh] Yeah.
Well, first of all, you
said something the other day
that I was just watching and I loved,
People fall like cheap chairs.
I believe, business is 80% mindset.
80% mindset.
I always put myself in the
most uncomfortable situations,
like just so everyone knows.
- Why?
- I'm gonna tell you why,
because putting yourself
in uncomfortable situations
allows you to get comfortable.
This is been going on four years,
but I never stop.
And you're just talking about a story,
and I'll share a really great story.
So when I first started my
company, it's GYMGUYZ with a Z
but I needed a S, why?
Because no one knew the brand yet,
and I knew people are gonna go to the S,
rather than the Z.
- GYMGUYS, the S at the end of guys
- It's with a Z now--
- I know that.
- Yes, but I needed the S,
because in the beginning of starting,
most people won't think like this.
- I get it
- People are going to come to that site
and I'm gonna lose business.
- [Gary] Of course.
Of course.
- So this guy Al, shout outs my man Al,
who's in Colorado, he was
selling the website for $48,000.
I was lucky if I had
48 cents in my pocket.
(Gary laughs)
So what I did was I literally googled,
looked up the domain went
on the site, you know,
and I called him once
twice, hang up, hang up,
hang up, hang up.
We're like 50 times in now.
I was like, you know what?
I got his address, I'm
gonna go to his house.
I book a flight to Colorado,
I go to his house--
- Before we go anywhere else Josh,
how many times have you been in jail?
- Never.
- Good, I love it.
- So, you know, even
though you're stalking,
you're doing it in a tasteful way
that doesn't scare people--
- [Josh] Listen--
- Because people are scary.
- Yeah, but not scary man.
- No, no, but you're
giving advice right now,
and like some people on
the other side right now
are gonna do the scary
version of it and be in jail.
So like, it's important for you
to break down.
- I understand, I understand.
- You agree with me right?
- Yeah
- I agree with you.
- Like, people go to fucking jail.
- Hundred percent, hundred percent--
- And you have a better tact than that.
I think actually, for no shits,
you have to figure out some
of the subtleness in that,
because some people are just like what,
some people will run
through this glass door
instead of opening it,
and in that is the punchline.
- Yup, Yup.
- Go ahead.
- So anyway so.
- You went to the fucking guy's house.
- I went to his house,
knocked on his door,
no one's there.
I'm like, I'll come back later.
No, one's there, shit.
I'm like I'm in a rural area.
So just with like eyesight,
you see the house down
like, all the way down.
Probably like a mile away.
Knock on the door.
Chances are, do you know Al?
"Oh, he's away with his family this week".
I'm like, you gotta be kidding me.
So I write a note, leave it to
his neighbor, go to his house
leave a note.
About two weeks later,
get a call from Allen.
He goes, you know,
"This is actually crazy now,
that you're stalking me".
I said, "Al, listen, I'm not stalking you,
"can you not feel my passion
dripping through your phone?"
I said, "I'm gonna build the largest
"fitness brand in the world.
"The chances of that not happening,
"you got a higher probability
"of seeing elephants fly".
On a 71st time he gave
me the site for free
Mike drop, right?
- Yeah.
- At the end of the day, you got to just,
if you believe in something,
- Just so much shit,
because, you know, I
think this is my podcast
and all I think about is the listeners
and how do I bring them value?
I'm just pumped that you're
gonna get this awareness
and people are gonna
love you and all that.
I mean that.
I think you know me well
enough at this point,
I really do mean that,
I'm excited for that to be good for you.
I'm passionate about them.
- Yes.
So, there's so many people
that I can't wait to put
restraining orders on,
because they there's a lot
of people that do this wrong.
- Hundred percent.
I'm serious.
Like let's really spend some,
before we get into like, we'll find time
for your part in this.
Straight up on some real shit,
- Yup.
- What do you think
allows you to go that hard
and get things done,
where 99, I'm gonna say it again.
99% of the people don't and end up
in really weird spaces
where they get in trouble,
they get restraining orders,
they lose their way,
like, do you think in
your tact, like what,
you know where I'm going right?
'Cause there's a real bad version of you.
- So--
- And I know a lot of those
people I've had those people.
I know unlimited people
that have those people
and those people really lose
because it's not just getting
gonna jail or a restraining order.
You get a reputation amongst winners.
And then you're a blacklisted
- Hundred percent.
- How do you feel
like you've been able to, what's
your gut tell you on that?
You may not even know the answer
- No, I do I do I do
I think, I think every
business in general, everyone's
in the people business.
I think the number one most important
thing is relationships.
And if you don't have, like
I know you and I connected right away.
Even when we met two years ago
in Vegas, I knew we had a connection
but I didn't go crazy and keep calling you
and calling you because I
knew that was the wrong plate.
You know, originally, I don't even know
if you know, I sent Tyler,
I shipped you a tire.
Yes. I remember that.
Yeah, and I wrote my driving and trace
to leave tread marks all over your floor,
and I know no one ever shipped you a tire.
So I was like, you know what?
I'll start with something
really out there.
- No, I remember Tyler came in.
He's like, dude, did you
meet some guy in Vegas?
I was like, yeah.
I met him in a side room.
Good guy, bald dude.
This is literally said.
- Did you say handsome?
- I didn't say that.
I said ball, dude.
I said, I remember this
moment like it was yesterday.
He's like,
"He sent a tire".
I'm like "Throw it away".
And went on my day.
- Yeah.
- But that's an important
part of the story.
- A hundred percent.
- 'Cause that actually happened.
Smart little move, Tyler comes in,
I'm like, "Fuck that, dude.
"I don't wanna fucking throw it away".
I'm like, "I know what he's doing".
Cause I know.
- I get it.
- Yeah.
I'm like throw that fucking,
now here's real truth,
and this is why everybody has to hear this
'cause I'm obsessed with
this episode bringing value.
The only reason I told
him to throw it away
was when he asked.
This is not a joke.
Know this.
Anybody that you're
desperate to meet is busy,
and is a firefighter.
- Hundred percent, 100%.
- So Tyler asked me a different moment
where like, a meeting got canceled
and I weirdly had two minutes to myself,
I would have like looked at it.
- Yeah.
- I would have loved it.
He asked me, I don't remember this part.
Inevitably, when a client fired us,
when I had a problem with
like an employee, right?
I was not in the right mindset
to have that hundredth of a second.
That is actually real life.
I Face Timed somebody on
Snapchat the other day
for five minutes, they want
a Twitter thing with me,
- Right.
- He said when I posted
him in either 92nd club
for like two seconds this year,
he posted it or I posted it,
and he said he had 800
friends reach out to him.
Like, just whatever the number was a lot.
And they're like,
"Oh my God, you got five
minutes of Gary Vee.
"I've watched every piece of
content of his for four years
"two years, nine years",
all these stories.
And he told me on the Face Time, he goes,
"I'm embarrassed because
"I'd only discovered you 40 days earlier",
and I was like, man, that's
so how life is, right?
This guy who discovered
me 40 days earlier,
and he gets this five minutes,
where there's people who
are listening right now
who've like been following
me for six years,
have desperately looked for five minutes
and it hasn't happened,
'cause that's that's real life.
That's not, I'm a bad guy.
That's not, you're unlucky.
We have to wrap our
head around serendipity
and look for the moments.
Keep going, please.
- Well, let me tell you something.
- I'm a big believer, and I
know you're down with this.
I think visualization is a very big,
important component to success.
Like I believe you have to,
like, I've visioned this.
Like I've actually seen this
- I believe you.
and I've obsessed over it.
Just like, again, we'll
go back to the jets,
I know for a fact that
you're gonna own the jets.
- You too.
- Cause I know you're obsessed with it.
You have to be so obsessed
but not to the point
where it's crazy.
- You scare the fuck,
out of people.
- Yeah, where you scare people.
It's gotta be calculating--
- Have you ever scared anybody?
- No, never man.
Absolutely not.
- Well, some people are
funny the other way.
- Yeah.
- Some people are scared
by me and I'm like, Jesus,
I'm not even--
- No, you're a nice guy, man.
- Alright.
- But so, you know, you have to--
- Now you have the S.
- Sorry, now I have
the S, got the website,
it's great, you know, and--
- Tell everybody the model,
'cause I think the model is interesting.
- Sure.
- 'Cause I think it's a replicatable model
for some hustlers listening.
- Absolutely, so--
- It's a franchisee business.
- It's a franchise business, right?
- But there's no physical location order.
- No locations.
- There's a van
- It's a van.
We bring the workout to you.
Home office, pool park, place of worship,
you wanna work on the closet,
you wanna do a VaynerMedia workout,
we literally bring all the
equipment right to you.
I will give you lifetime free sessions
just because I'm gonna
provide more value to you,
I'll let my team workout your whole crew
in here for free.
For free that's on record.
- Understood.
- That's number one.
- Number two, we literally bring
the workout anywhere, okay?
We're disrupting the fitness industry.
Right now we are literally
the fastest growing
in the fitness space.
You think of like--
It makes sense, right?
Like if somebody wants to buy
these other gym franchise,
I assume--
- It's like a million dollars investment--
Right, and how much is it for--
- One territory, $80,000.
- And how big is the territory.
- It's 100,000 people.
So in that territory,
you're gonna get 10,000
approved households.
- I see.
- Over a certain immediate income.
And what is that level?
- So it's really based on obviously
the demographics of the area,
sound graphics
- Right cause Alabama
might be different than
your, yeah of course.
- It's cost of living and all that,
but, you know, I started this
with $15,000 bootstrapped--
- How did you know to do
franchisee franchisor?
Had you seen that model?
Did you see something?
- No so, I didn't learnt,
I didn't know anything about
it, but when I started this
in my parents' dining room,
I said, I'm gonna franchise
this business and just build--
- Why did you say that?
McDonald's?
- Because, no, because I liked the fact--
Orange theory, like
what was on your radar?
Like take me deeper.
- I like the fact that,
you could bring a lot of
great smart minds together
and build a very powerful brand.
And I wanna create it.
This is what I said.
I wanna create a powerful movement,
that I could bring everyone together.
Because if you know,
McDonald's the dollar menu
the McFlurry, those are
all started by Franchisees.
I don't have all the
answers, just like you don't
and we can learn from each other.
Everyone can learn from each other.
But when you're allowed
to surround yourself
with great people, you could
build things at a faster speed.
- So you thought that was smart?
- I thought it was genius.
- Mm-hm.
- Yeah.
The model of Franchisees franchisor
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, it's an American--
- - Comes with a lot of headaches though.
You know, I listened to you--
- Of course, one dope with
a van can fuck you up.
- A hundred percent.
Look being an...
everyone thinks it's so cool.
Listen, lay down on the
road, let a car drive over,
go on reverse, drive you over,
then you'll get a break
for like three, four weeks,
lay down again, it's
gonna go over you again,
and back.
- What was the hardest moment?
So, when did you start this?
- I started this in 2008.
- On some real shit, because
I wanna bring real value.
- Making payroll for almost 10 years,
every single two weeks,
I had to figure out how to make it--
I think he told me over lunch, a scary one
where you were like really--
Gee, I was in a casino right?
- Right.
Yeah, she told me that.
- I drove to the casino, do not do this,
I didn't do it, but don't listen to me,
what I'm gonna tell you now.
So I'm in a casino,
I had my life savings,
I only had five grand left
and I was like, all
right, I need 20 Grand.
If I could hit red, red's
obviously our color, you know,
I was like, if I can hit red,
- Then I'll have 10
- Then I'll have 10,
and I'm gonna double it
and I can make payroll.
- So what happened again?
- So I sat there--
- You called somebody--
- Yeah, I called someone
who's very successful
who's like been a mentor to me.
And I was like, "So you
think this is a good idea?"
He's like.
(both laughs)
- Hey, I'm in Atlantic city.
I need to make payroll.
It's 20,000.
I have 5,000.
I'm gonna put it on red red.
Do you think it's a good idea?
He's like
"Josh It is the stupidest idea ever"--
- Josh you're the stupidest
fucker I've ever met.
- Yeah but he's like,
"But you got the biggest
set I've ever seen
"in my life.
"You're crazy doing that"--
- He loved it?
- So, Oh, he loved it.
Loved it.
And this guy's self-made, very successful.
- So he loved it.
- So I said, you know, it's a stupid idea.
So I went back to my office.
Now this is what I can't see yet--
- And you called everybody, right?
I remembered.
- I called every single client--
- I've a good memory.
I'm proud of myself right now.
- G, come here.
- Thank you.
- So I called every single client--
- and a company, yeah.
and I gave away over
hundreds of free sessions
and raised 46 Grand overnight.
Now, I couldn't take credit
cards cause I needed the money
in the bank.
So I literally, I drove
to everyone's house
to collect checks.
If you're listening to
this and you complain
and you're hanging out
at home on the weekend,
that's a problem.
This is why people don't
get to the next level.
- This, that $6 coffee thing
that I had clarity about
the other day.
I don't mind $6 copies.
I don't mind $70,000 pairs of sneakers.
I get mad when people complain
and do things that make no sense.
- Hundred percent.
- To me this is just about complaining
You could go buy a boat, a Rolex,
that means you haven't
a peep of complaining.
The second you go
into complaining mode,
I'm auditing the fuck out of you.
- G, do you know how many DMS I get a day?
And I don't have a lot.
I'm still liking early stages.
- Two.
- Yeah, like three, four or five,
but anyway, I get DMS out of there.
Oh, you wanna grow your following?
No, no, no, no.
And people like, why don't
you wanna grow your following?
You should have millions of followers.
Because it takes time.
Half the stuff out there is fake.
- Half?
- Probably 90%.
G, heard there's a business. Now
that you can rent a private jet, a car
and a whole setup for
an hour to do a shoot,
to pretend like you own it.
- Brother.
- That's genius.
- People have been doing that,
like people have been jumping fences
to take photos that they're
going on a private plane
at scale.
- Crazy.
It's crazy.
- We also live in a
world where 22 year olds
are having plastic surgery.
- I know, I know.
It's crazy.
All that people wanna do is make pretend.
- Listen--
- They're successful--
- You're gonna love this
- You're gonna love
this, it's great content.
You know this tune?
Teren ten teren ten ten.
- Yep.
- Okay. Marah brothers, right?
- You can compare that to
entrepreneurship any day
of the week,
'cause you always get to
live to see another day.
But in some situations, I mean, you know,
like you'll die, but you can
start at a certain point.
'cause you got to a certain
point and you can continue
without having to go back--
- Yeah like 3.1,
even though you almost got to the end--
- Exactly.
But you know,
sometimes you could take
10 steps back to move 24
and sometimes you take five
steps back to move 10 forward.
I'm more like up, up, down,
down left, right left, right.
B, A, B, A select start,
because that's unlimited lives.
- I love it.
Listen, I love it.
- That's how my entrepreneurship works.
- Look man.
- Contra bitch.
(both laugh)
Look, you know, it's funny.
You know, you and I agree
with so many different things,
like school, for example,
you know, I look back
to school, like I was a horrible student.
Horrible.
Didn't excite me, didn't love it.
And people go to college,
they waste all their money.
I think people should
literally be working for people
who've done it.
- I apologize for interrupting you.
How old--
- I'm 36.
- Now, and so that means
you started when you were--
- 25.
- 25?
Talk to me about 20 to 25.
- Oh man.
- Were you a knucklehead?
- No, I was just depressed man.
- You were?
- Yeah.
- Tell me why.
- I didn't know what I
wanted to do in my life.
You know, people were like driving around,
see, you know, I had a
rough life growing up, rough
and listen--
- Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in New high
park on Long Island.
Rough life, you know?
But, you can't make excuses man.
- No I understand.
- Whatever card you're dealt,
deal with them--
- Listen, people win three
seven off suit all the time.
- That's it, you just deal with them.
You deal with them and honestly,
I wouldn't change a thing
in my life because--
- What resentment did you
have built up at that point?
Did you wanna be rich?
- No.
Listen, if you chase the
money, you got a problem.
- Agreed.
You cannot chase the money.
I'll tell you that right now.
So many people have a twist in the wrong,
I've always wanted,
I love fitness.
I've always loved fitness.
- Really.
Loved it.
The problem is doctors and
trainers are exactly the same.
A doctor without patients is unemployed,
trainer without clients is unemployed.
And we say, how can I make
money when I'm not working?
'Cause you got to work on your business
not in your business.
- Yeah.
- I need to get paid--
- So you were a trainer?
- I was a trainer.
- I see.
- And people used to
always laugh at me and,
"Look at you, Joshua working at the gym
"you're a trainer making $10 an hour",
- Did you like it?
- No I loved it.
- When they made fun of you.
- No I didn't care.
Cause I just say, you just wait here.
- Didn't hear?
_No I don't, I tuned that stuff,
listen, I got a problem.
It's my neck.
I look this way only.
I never turned back this way.
You make a mistake, that's it.
Someone's gonna Sue you.
This is the things that
gonna happen in business.
People are gonna Sue you.
People are gonna lie to you.
- What are you most excited about?
Like when you, like now dream, right?
You've got this thing
rolling a little bit, like--
- Oh it's rolling.
- Yeah.
What do you really,
how do you think about,
you know, it's funny when
you said you're obsessed
with the jets.
It's really funny.
I'm obsessed with chasing the jets.
Like it's crazy how much
I like process over,
let me give you an example.
You know, a lot about me right?
you paid attention.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- You know anything about this?
I mean it, like real talk.
You know anything about it?
- That I do not know.
- That is the single biggest
exit in the history of my life.
- Wow.
- That's a company called Resee.
- Resee
- That years ago I started
with Ben Leventhal,
then we brought over Mike Monteiro.
It was incubated at VaynerMedia.
It was part of the Vayner
RC fund that I had.
We started it because I
didn't wanna just invest,
I wanted to build,
and Ben and Mike did an incredible job.
I was on the board.
There was a time when a
company was struggling,
I put personal money into
it, real cheque for me
at the time,
and it exited to Amex
within the last year,
maybe nine months ago,
maybe a year ago for hefty nine figures.
- That's great--
- It is the single
biggest win on my record.
- It's great.
- Nobody knows anything about it.
- Yeah.
- I'm trying to remember why I said this.
Oh, I like the process.
- Yeah.
- Not the winning moment.
- I hear you, man.
It's funny you say that because, you know,
like I was telling some people, you know,
I'm with Gary today and they're like,
"Oh my God, that's amazing.
"That's great".
- He's so handsome.
Like what else did they say?
And like, you know,
you're a stud, you know,
scruff looks great,
you know, good hoodies,
but , I didn't look at it like that.
Like I really like truly believe you and I
are gonna have a good
connection past this,
and I got some big things like,
we'll talk off record, but
I was just excited to just come
here and just provide value
and just, look, I've always been about,
when I get a call from
a woman who's 414 pounds
that couldn't have bariatric surgery,
that was drinking 17 Slurpees a day.
and all she wanted to do is have a family
and have children.
- Good for her.
- And I personally changed her life.
- Yeah that's insane.
- And she's 160 pounds
and she literally wants to
get my name tattooed on her.
She calls me once a month,
like I get emotional sometimes.
It's crazy.
- I get it.
- Or like when someone's mom calls you up
'cause their kids being picked on
'cause they have no
confidence and you help them.
Like that moves me--
- Legacy
- Yeah, that moves me.
I wanna continue to do that,
'cause look
in the fitness world,
people are procrastinators.
People can't turn on a machine.
They can't open an app.
- Dude, it's so unbelievable back to,
you mean eliminating friction?
- Yeah.
- Listen, it's the half-pregnant version.
Your model is I understand super well
because I think I can
afford having a babysitter.
Like the fact that in two hours,
Mike Vacanti is coming here.
By the way I learned
something about myself.
I'm getting much better workouts
in, in the evening than
I am in the morning.
So I've like changed that up a little bit.
But like I needed a babysitter.
- You need accountability.
- Yeah.
- Everyone needs accountability
- And you'll never believe this.
Everybody who's listening.
That's such a good point by Joshua.
Let me tell you about my accountability.
I am not accountable to myself.
I'm accountable to others.
That's why I'm such a good leader.
- Yeah.
- I think more about Jason and Dust...
Like I feel like I work for them for real.
And once I figure that
out with workout, I'm like
wait a minute,
If I get a full time
trainer who babysits me,
I don't wanna let that,
literally I'm doing well,
'cause I don't wanna let Mike down.
It's any one moment in the last six years
that I caught a little bit of a flop,
which was the back half of last year.
It's cause Jordan, my trainer,
who kinda looks like you
by the way, Jordan, my trainer at the time
was burnt out.
We was three years.
He crushed.
I mean, by the way, between
soft tissue work and like,
in a lot of ways brought
me, I don't wanna say more.
Mike and Jordan have transformed my life
as going back and forth as my trainers,
But what I asked him to do was impossible
which is, fuck your life,
It's 100% of my life,
you travel on my schedule
when I want, right?
And he wore down.
And as soon as he wore down
and started like, like kind
of like, I'm not gonna travel
with you on this trip,
which led to not coming.
Like I'm sick, like we both worn down
and, I mean five and a half years crushed.
I can't wait to look back at the content
of mine from November, December last year,
'cause I know I'm like 15 pounds,
like I'm already down 12...
Like I just need a babysitter
because Jordan lost his way.
I wasn't accountable to
him anymore, which I lost.
If you're trying for me,
I'm accountable for you.
And that's what I needed.
- Yeah.
- And I think for a lot of
people listening right now,
I think the biggest reason
that you're not eating well or working out
is you're like me.
You can't, you're not
competitive with yourself.
I've never wanted to
beat myself in anything.
If you're like, Oh, today I'm running.
I'm gonna run it faster today.
I'm like, beat yourself?
Fuck that.
I wanna beat somebody else.
I wanna be accountable to somebody else.
Once I figured that out, it
changed my life with fitness.
I think that's, I'm just saying that.
'cause I hope for one person
they figure out, Oh wait a minute.
I can't afford a trainer
that travels with me
like Garry, but I'm gonna
buddy up with somebody.
And I'm gonna be accountable to them
and they're gonna be accountable to me.
I think I couldn't agree with you more.
That's a really great insight.
- Yeah.
And you said something that was golden.
You said that you work for them.
You know, I say that all the time,
people don't understand
that a good leaders always
create other good leaders.
It's very important to understand.
And at the end of the day,
when you're like thinking that, you know,
someone else, your employee,
like, I hate that word.
I'm not a fan of it.
I don't know if you're a
fan of that word at all?
- You know what's so funny.
I'm really funny with words.
I think we're in a hypersensitive America
where people analyze words,
I care about intent.
To your point,
I understood where you're going
and I appreciate it.
For me personally,
I'll use any word.
I'm curious about action.
- Action.
Yeah, you know what I mean?
- I agree.
- Like I'm thrilled to
call Dessa my employee,
but like how I treat him is like you know,
also I think I put
certain words on pedestals
that are not, to your point,
I think you were saying the same thing.
- Yeah.
- And I think, yeah.
- Emotional intelligence.
I live by it.
- It's the game.
- 100%.
- What do we need to touch
on before we get out of here?
'Cause it's all moved so fast.
- Oh yeah.
- What have we not talked about?
What do we have not touched on?
- Listen, honestly, I think
it's been pretty good,
You know?
I think it's been pretty good, you know.
- What do you, actually you
didn't answer this question
'cause I probably cut you off,
Cause I'm good at that.
What--
- So am I.
- What are you excited about
in like 10 or 15 or 20?
Like, what do you dream about now, right?
Like, what are you thinking about?
Like, let me ask some fun questions.
Do you think your company will go public?
- Not sure.
- Do you think you'll sell it?
- Yes.
- So you think more likely a
private equity firm buys it
at a big scale--
- But a minority, a minority.
- Understood.
Okay, so you wanna sell--
- Listen, I've turned down
a lot of money already.
- I believe you.
You're gonna get to the
apex moment that you feel
in your heart, take
some money off the board
so you can feel that win--
- My wife won't listen to this,
so we're okay,
But I've never even shared with her,
If I shared with her, she'll kill me.
What I've turned down, because I believe,
you gotta believe.
If you don't believe
you're never going anywhere
you have to really believe.
- The amount of people that
sold too early is all time.
- It's crazy.
You gotta believe.
Everyone wants instant.
There's no such thing as instant.
- I was on CNN the day
Instagram sold to Facebook
for a billion dollars,
500 days in the company,
and I said that Facebook stole it,
I got shit on, I'm historically correct.
- You are.
(both mumble)
Now, who knows if they
would have been able
to scale that?
I think Kevin was the--
- The reason people sell out is because
- They want it.
- Yeah, but the game is also so hard
that people just walk away.
And, I was talking to a guy the other day.
He walked away,
'cause he said he couldn't
handle it anymore.
- And by the way, I respect that.
- Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
- There really isn't.
No, like, I'm gonna throw
you a real curve ball.
I will have no judgment against myself,
if I wake up one morning
and say, you know what?
I don't wanna do this.
I wanna like, I'm thinking
about selling everything
and just becoming a
sports car dealer again.
'Cause I'm really hot on
it for a couple of years.
No, but I really think to
your point, we enjoy it.
- Yeah.
- Like to me the second I don't like it,
is a second I'll be a DNF student.
You know what this part of me I love,
being against the wall.
Part of me loves it.
- Well, you know what's interesting
that I'm curious if this
is gonna happen to you,
I think the reason I've jumped around
and done a lot of shit is
I'm only most comfortable
when I'm an underdog.
- I love it.
- I actually hate what's
going on with Gary Vee.
You know, I'm a little bit scared a bit.
I'm like, fuck, I'm gonna
start getting overrated.
You know, with all the
things that are happening,
I feel like if I get into
a place where I'm like
I'm starting a coffee brand
and everyone collectively
or the majority is like,
Oh, this is gonna crush,
I'm gonna be in trouble.
That's why the sports car
thing is so fun for me.
Like, I know my inner circle
and I know my community,
people shitted on me quietly,
'cause now it's a little scarier to shit
on me publicly because
I've been right enough.
But like, people were like no way.
And like, that's why I like it so much.
- Yeah.
I still got my hockey car
collection, by the way
if you ever want--
- Hockey's dead.
- I know, I just love--
- Listen, I love the sport.
Nobody gives a fuck.
- Yeah.
But I'm a big hockey guy.
No I get it.
It's just not enough demand.
Supply demand issues.
- I hear you.
- Okay.
Do you wanna be a famous entrepreneur?
- Well, I think that kinda
comes with the territory.
I should keep growing.
- Mm-mm.
There's people way
bigger than me and Cuban
and Daymond John and
everybody that nobody knows
who the fuck they are.
Do you like kind of the, the limelight
of like a winning
entrepreneur, you like that?
- To some degree, to some degree.
- Does it scare you to
admit more of, to the ring?
Cause I think a lot about this, right?
- Some yeah--
- Like is it douchey,
is it narcissistically?
I'm empathetic to it--
- I think--
It's an interesting question.
- Here's what I think.
I never include my family in anything like
in social media.
I'm not that guy.
I worry about that.
Like sometimes I think about with you,
like, when you're out with your family
and people are coming up to you
- You know, what's
funny, by not sharing it,
people understand the rules a little bit.
- Yeah.
- The fact that I never share
my life, my personal life,
people are gonna always say what's up.
But like, it's crazy.
If I'm solo, I'm into
like, in the right moments,
it's beetle me.
Like I can't believe how many
people who know the fuck I am,
but when I'm doing
personal stuff and my kids
like things of that nature,
like people do it different.
They'll give you the wink,
like whereas, they'll take
the selfie if I'm solo
and come in, like pitch me their idea
or ask me a question or take a selfie,
when I'm with them, it's
more of like that respect,
like wink wink,
'cause they know like, fuck,
I've never seen his kids,
You know?
- Yeah, that's kinda cool, I like it.
- It's kinda cool.
Like some people don't, back
to like, who's going to jail,
some people don't have
emotional intelligence
and they steamroll, and then I'm,
I'm not pissed.
I'm actually empathetic, but
I'm definitely not open to it.
It's like the tire.
Tyler showed me the tire
at the wrong second,
if you're gonna roll up on
me and pitch your business
without even asking when I'm
holding my two kids' hands
there's a 100% chance
that I fucking hate you.
- Yeah.
I agree.
- Like, you know, but if
you like kind of like,
"Hey, do you have a second?
"I know you're with your family",
already I hundred percent love you.
I'll still probably
say no, it's like tact.
- Yeah
- It's like tact.
You know what's so funny?
I don't even actually
hate you a hundred percent
'cause I'm still so fucking flattered
that anybody would wanna ask me,
that I can never get
away from that feeling,
But it's kinda like,
Hey, you know the score like be kind,
but I get it, 'cause you
get excited and you think
this is your only shot.
I get it.
I understand it.
It still doesn't make me feel like,
my kids get upset.
- Yeah, I'm sure
- They don't get enough time with me.
So then like somebody pitching me is not
like how they wanna spend
that Saturday afternoon.
- Right?
- So that breaks my heart.
You know, it's just a whole fucking thing.
- I'll tell you something else.
Look, my GYMGUYZ franchise family members
is the number one who I serve.
And the ability that I could bring people
into my system, just like I changed,
what's her name's life,
Donna and everyone else,
and I could help people run
a successful business model--
- That's the best.
- Especially when like that
to me is, and it's the best
because it's selfless and selfish.
If you're doing that for
Dustin as a franchisee,
it's the best feeling
and you're winning too.
And that's okay.
I keep telling my friends,
I'm like, I love making
people happy and feeling good.
I also wanna fucking build an empire.
You can do both.
Right now, we're in this
world where you can't do both.
It's crazy.
- Build an empire.
- I wanna build an empire
in the nicest way of all time,
because the world's abundant.
Your empire and his empire and his empire
and Shi'ar empire are not
at the expense of my empire.
Like, if you're good enough,
you can't stop winners.
- Can't
- Can't stop them.
- Can't.
No way.
If you're a winner,
you're gonna keep winning.
That's it?
- What's your Instagram handle?
- It's joshyorkgg.
- joshyorkgg?
What's the GG?
GYMGUYZ.
- I know (chuckles)
- Come on man (mumbles)
- I'm trying to see, that
was stocked into Malone.
I know what the fucking--
- Always be branding.
if you're not,
I literally went to a conference recently
everyone in the whole room,
they all have businesses.
I'm the only one branding,
I was actually speaking.
I was the only one branding.
Why are you not branding?
That's an opportunity to
talk about your company
and get out to somebody else.
You've gotta always be out there branding.
It's very important.
- If you believe in what you're selling,
there's nothing better.
- That's it.
- Thanks for being on brother.
- Thank you for having me G